uh but it's it's it's a journey it's not
see it's not it's easy to share it you
know the person to talk about a virtual
perspective but you know when you're
there you'll start you're stressful
you're coming to meeting no no what to
do how to a
to to deal with you know this
this type of person you know
traditionally and but and you need to
learn you need in the world to ask
questions and sometimes they like you
know this is really
a way that we are very direct sometimes
you need to be sensitive but sometimes
this direct help you know to
to get things the sooner better a and
much more you know precise and accurate
than going around you know in the
culture that you need to to be very
careful
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i am with sharon alalu
vice president of business development
day pack cellwise
sharon a mother to three amazing boys
and a spouse who is a successful artist
fortunate with them follow her to the
other side of the world to explore the
global business scene while enjoying the
multicultural experience of asia she is
proud that she moved from her comfort
zone and managed to have a triple career
transformation local to global
technology to business and customer side
to vendor side
more than 20 years of divertive career
inspired by leaders that shape and
highlight the importance of believing in
herself and her achievements currently
she is the vice president of business
development at cellwise
[Music]
well shiron you
you have a fascinating journey and i
want to sort of piece it together over
these 20 minutes but really um
my goal here is to understand
this bigger question of open-mindedness
and living life in an extraordinary way
and
just from a few minutes
understanding of
from you explaining to me what your life
is like you know it sounds to me like
it's almost as if you've uncovered
something very
foundational to what it means for some
people to be human and you're exercising
it in a really authentic and amazing way
so sharon tell me just a little bit
about
you know yourself and a little bit about
your career trajectory just so that we
understand the high level pieces and
then we'll and then we'll piece them
together
sure so we'll start there from the end
so
hey today i'm living here with my family
i have uh three boys 18 16 and 12 we
live in bangkok we live in asia for the
last six years
we started our relocation journey in
singapore for three years which was an
amazing experience
then we moved to bangkok then coffee
they joined us and in the last three
years we live here amazing in the heart
of the city of bangkok
a
managing no international life
you know expert life
with all the meaning
uh and yes i can say that if you i'm
trying to look back
you know one of the
funniest things that we are looking at
when you are going to vacation
and my first trip after the army in 1996
i was in thailand
if you will ask me back then if i can
imagine myself living here with my
family and running a
career
it was kind of a joke
for sure and sometimes you know i'm
sending a
photo there for my friend did with me
they said no backpacking a tour
and look at the magic again copy pcc
it's the same
the same street used to to go it's just
a bit renovated so it kind of
unbelievable
and yes
i look at you know my where we are it's
kind of transformation of career i
started my journey and
back in the 2000 day that you know when
the the market in israel was booming you
know with all these
a high tech scene
every several years there is high tech
scenes so i'm old enough to to share the
experience uh we just stay graduating
you know the day it was an amazing
opportunity they
did the market and i started my journey
in a in a startup company called the
selwa no services could go next they'd
have been acquired by telephone and then
most of my a career was technology
career i used to manage the r d a
department therefore well the value of
the services so imagine we started with
the black and white mobile phone a
till
to the journey to the iphone and most of
my xa activities was around you know rnd
managing several day
teams and i ran in the world this unit
that was responsible for the
thing that today is coming come kind of
all this but you know what the music's
application before spotify or the super
tv before
uh
netflix all this was you know a
technology that we ran almost more than
10 years ago so it was really amazing
you know where a technology journey
i seek more than eight years nine years
i decided that you know this is the time
to to do the transformation
i i think i take it step by step i was
not imagining where i'm going to
and then i decided i i call it the
triple transformation so moving from
being a customer most of the year that
all the vendor is
running around you and share with your
technology and you need just to pick and
choose fill your
to be a vendor to be the one that is
running after the scouting out after the
new customers
from a
a local company israel a telephone was
israeli company everything was in hebrew
all the sins was in hebrew except some
meetings you know with international
vendors to do it to to global company
when everything you know is around the
globe and you're traveling you know you
go and bake here on a weekly basis
and also from technology activities that
i used to run you know big huge projects
of millions or ten of millions of
dollars
to run a business that need to bring a
millions of dollars and it was kind of
you know it was it was not easy at the
beginning you need to know
it's a different mindset
it's a different you know state of mind
you know how to how to craft how to
build it from scratch i i came to andox
to build a a digital business unit which
was you know something that we have been
kind of a mini startup in the big giant
dumb docks and we had the very
successful uh activities in very short
time so because we grew away quickly
from i started
by myself and then after four months
we've been you know kind of 25 people i
can tell it's one of my a
one moment after three months i need to
go to to partner with two a big partners
like one of them was a adobe
when i i went to meet them in their
offices in manhattan you know it's kind
of
i can't believe i'm here and with frog
design which is kind of it was enough
for me from the israeli scene to go to
to to you to work with such
a big brands and do business with them
in the digital and i'm telling you it's
eight years ago today digital is
everywhere but even then it was
something that it was kind of unique in
the telecommunication business
and it was really amazing experience and
learned a lot
and then you know kind of okay after one
and a half years okay so what's next we
know how to travel every every week do
away another place in the globe where
what we'll do now and then i told my
boss which was inspiring one
and he gave me a lot of you know
things you know dude how to to to build
all this you know business and that i
want to relocate he told me okay so
canada
he had some business in nation
i don't know
asia i say asia really where it's
are you sure yes okay let's build you a
position
so in three four months
i found myself with my family
in singapore
um
shocking in the beginning but you know
singapore is embracing his kind of you
know is the the manhattan official
uh
very fortunate you know to start a
relocation in such place and we had
amazing trees you know in the beginning
also you need to start to come to the
office
everyone you know
very few israelis you will get used to
need to walk you know people around the
globe need to understand culture and to
be sensitive for the forward staff to
start to build a relationship with
customers you know
we're gonna we're gonna pick up exactly
where we left off and but what i do want
to wanna
also understand sharon is
this idea of open-mindedness so you're
describing
career-wise this this
this notion that you have inside of you
that that it's okay to make transitions
it's okay to think different it's okay
to develop different understandings and
to jump into
into uncharted territory whether it be
business opportunities going from local
to global changing languages changing
cultures whether it be even relocating
and what i'm trying to piece at right
now is sort of what is inhibiting us you
know foundationally from from being open
to these types of changes and and
what was sort of the
the internal motivation that allowed you
to make those leaps eventually
first uh to move you need to move you
know it's everything every time you are
kind of surprised from experience from
the thing that you know you will not get
used to
and
it's starting from the day by day the
school activities in your work
environment and you just need you know
to
to to just flow or flow with it and you
know sometimes you know it's a stressful
day you need to make sure that you're
doing the right you know the right
stability you're in the right place that
you are not a a
it's okay to you know it's okay you know
don't do control everything that you get
used to here before and not in your own
you know a natural environment and once
you're accepting it and you know you
understand people are accepting it
because i think also the nice
place to start the education in
singapore
that most of your environmental experts
are
similar in the cube they'll most likely
experience similar
challenges that your experience
and once you succeed you know to find
this common
a discussion and and you are get putting
it aside and running you know to the
main thing that you you can to do the
it's become a
it's starting to feel natural uh but
it's it's a journey it's not see it's
not it's easy to share it you know the
person to talk about a virtual
perspective but you know when you're
there you'll start you're stressful
you're coming to meeting no know what to
do how to a
to to deal with you know this
this type of person you know
traditionally and but and you need to
learn you need in the world to ask
questions
and sometimes they like you know this is
really
a way that we are very direct sometimes
you need to be sensitive but sometimes
this direct help you know to to
to get things the sooner better a and
much more you know precise and accurate
than going around you know within the
culture that you need to to be very
careful but
you need you know you need to be careful
you need to learn it but you need also
sometimes you know to just to there and
to do it and you know
angle but
yes it is something you need you know to
adapt and every time you know once
you're in singapore
they they usually most of the the
position in singapore are a regional
position
which means it's not about understanding
the singapore and understanding the
filipino understanding you know the
indian end of turning you know traveling
to australia the japanese so it's a
multicultural environment business
environment that you need to adapt and
you need to do to make sure that you
understand uh to avoid uh basic mistakes
that you can do potentially and then you
know today well it's a globally scene
hey i think if you will ask me i used to
work 20 years ago
in intel they used to train the people
what to do when you're traveling to
japan today in a global world that you
know everything is open everything is is
is exposed to you you need to do it by
yourself so it's kind of make sure that
you come prepared uh
and sometimes you're running many things
in parallel so you need to juggle
between between all this but
it's there it's then i am still
expecting you to to act like this even
today when i uh starting another
discussion with japanese
uh
and i work for example with my agent
they kind of give us you know kind of
direction please do they don't do that
they are getting
insulted if you will do that so i'm
trying you know to get their their
guidance
uh to make sure that we are doing the
things right first and not you know
wasting hours without going rounds or
making you know some impolite actually
right and you probably also you know you
learn as you travel and as you relocate
and continue through these transitions
i'm guessing that besides you know the
ability to adapt to new cultures you
also develop an understanding and
um
a deeper understanding that the way that
you're acting in in one way may be
perceived differently by the person on
the other end and and so it's important
for you to sort of be this investigator
wherever you go to figure out okay how
is my personality now going to be
translated to this culture and even
asking this question it's not a trivial
thing to do because we're used to being
around people that you know that are
like us or that know us because this is
where we grow up and
not everybody moves like you throughout
the world so
i think there is an interesting
personal insight to to be taken here
from this curiosity this questioning of
of self
yes first you know first thing is always
to smile to them then you are good right
now to break the
the eyes when you are meeting people it
is all it's usually easy to start but
you you need to understand you know for
example in thailand i managed to
understand that the hierarchy is very
important that we are coming with the
culture that is now hierarchy and they
when you are trying you know to to
continue on this a
a man
it sometimes don't work they may they
may even not appreciate it as you wanted
to they will proceed
in the level that you are coming to
discuss with people
so i can tell that it's something it's
ongoing you always need to be sensitive
uh sometimes if you want to know to
arrange a call with someone executing
you cannot call it by yourself if you
will do it it's kind of you are
it's your downgrade you so
it seems that you know in the today in
in a
in our environment you know when we are
working in a big opening small company
we are not getting used to i have my
secretary i have my team
and here sometimes it's it's
it's just traditional and you need to
play the game and uh sometimes they just
say okay but why let's just do direct
let's let's let me watch the po and then
jump on a call because
i want it today not day in three weeks
when you will be so you almost need to
to to understand that patient sometimes
you know is is the key to to get things
uh and i also one of them
a
important thing we manage a lot it's
kind of timing and they um
to be very patient because things are
not getting working in the pace that you
want them to do to
to be they see the environment the
business involvement in asia
is slow
uh and you cannot understand why all
every time asking but what is the
compelling event how come you are not
a passion to close it you know tomorrow
and start to save money and start to
improve everything this is the way the
business and i'm always questioning
myself and questions try to politely
question them
how come we are dealing with such topic
for more than you know a
a for months
so a thing that you need you know always
not to control yourself to understand
that this is
a
this is the environment scene and you
need to play accordingly in order to to
to continue become and being relevant uh
for the
prospects and the customer that you are
walking be waiting for
so
i want to wrap up the
conversation about
about moving and about open-mindedness
and the dynamics talking a little bit
about you know the family side of things
because
until now you know we understand yes
it's difficult
to do it both professionally and
personally and asking the right
questions etc but
when you have a family with husbands
three kids and and you're still managing
to maintain this open-mindedness how
does that work what what is that like
well if you will ask them today what is
there in our experience
for the last six years at least they are
kind of
uh
happy from these wolves so the dancer
will be totally and they all every time
we are challenging them even so i can
tell there are some challenges you know
being here comparing to the
regular
environment you know that they get used
to in israel it's different in the
international scene however they
they the fact that you know kind of the
kind of
global age children that they
going to international school and having
friends from people around the globe
uh it's a gift
uh it's a gift you know in my in the
second year of my son when he was in the
eighth grade either they have kind of a
a debate and he need to
defend iran
which is amazing that israel you know a
student need to defend a
it's kind of you say wow and in the game
you know with a lot of you know good
arguments so it's like they don't care
no about you know what we're dealing you
know and by the day what they get used
to to hear
and their mindset is different you know
they were they the way they're talking
about you know where global things are
kind of
fascinating
and yes it's it's not obvious even so we
will get get used to that you know that
everyone is kind of engaged i think the
experience we had
and from the family perspective
traveling around you know asia like
before corbin it was gone every three
months exploring new zealand australia
it's it's amazing family bonding that
you have
and yet you know the family in israel is
always happy to say okay so what's next
when you're coming back and you say okay
but maybe maybe next year my weeks
but from the family perspective is kind
of bonding and we manage also to build
you know also here and also in singapore
kind of you know friends with that
become family i'm usually every every
friday night in my house is more than 20
25 people that everyone is still always
at home with their natural environment
with friends
and
in the other day we are far from the
real family and it's important you know
to make sure that the holidays and and
saturday and weekend become um
cozy as they get used to
uh
and and every time i'm hearing them i
think that the the how they developed
over the six years it's
it's really you know we are really lucky
to to get this opportunity
to get to this journey
uh for me i feel natural that we are
already here but even every people
started i'm coming to restaurant people
ask me about you know the experience how
you are dealing with all this you know
they
a
life you know their lifestyle
it's really fun to have also people you
know friends in our way
that they
care from different people from
indonesia you have friends from india
and you know understand better culture
and get you know much more interesting
discussion sometimes that you don't you
you and you'll not get used to
i love it yeah it's it's amazing
i really really love it that's really
really incredible if you will ask me
again like wow again let's let's start
over
i i think it's really
really incredible and i'm i'm personally
taking a lot of inspiration from from it
and the open-mindedness and and i love
the note about conversations and about
getting exposed to different people
asking different questions that we don't
normally get to ask in our day-to-day
and so shawn i really want to thank you
for for spending this time with me
it's a it's a fascinating journey both
professionally and also personally
and and i wish you best of luck with
cell wise and everything else that
you'll do
and
until then stay safe and stay healthy
and continue travel and continue making
amazing experiences for you and your
family
it's really remarkable thank you very
much thank you for the opportunity i
hope this will inspire the other
families mostly
women and to take you know to be
courageous enough you know to take their
family and you know go to adventure and
it
just you know flow with them and you
know just good things happening when
you're
a getting out from your comfort zone
i love it thank you sean take care great
thank you very much